which is another thing I want to talk to
you about Tito Chuck yeah as a guy who's
retired who had an awesome career and
you're watching that and he's seen a guy
come back at 50 and get stopped like
that what does what did that do for you
you kind of knew that well I felt that
Chuck shouldn't be taking that fight
right
Tito's been competing Tito's still in
there yeah and then when they stepped in
as soon as they touched up it's like
yeah Chuck shouldn't be in here
he looked that's the first time he
looked that much smaller than Tito he
didn't look the same size as Tito he
didn't look comfortable
he didn't look as coordinated like Chuck
was always little quirky and awkward in
his movement but he didn't even look
like Chuck Liddell right he looked like
a shell of Chuck Liddell and as opposed
to see him hitting the pads like recent
video of him hitting the pounds no did
it look terrible yeah see he said he was
just warming up like you talked to
Brendan Schaub about it says I always
look bad when I'm warming up but I'm
like it's not just that look we looked
like his balance was off wait I get that
I would see if I would have saw that
beforehand I still wouldn't put a whole
lot of stock in that because like I
remember being a lock on before fought
Hermes franck of the first time in your
seat and Nick Diaz was in our locker
room and [ __ ] hitting pads and he's
about to fight Robbie and he's hitting
pads and he's like yeah I'm gonna knock
this [ __ ] out yeah and I'm like
not hit nosepads like he didn't look
like he didn't look sharp he didn't look
like Eddie power and anyone out there
knocked Robbie out well he probably was
just warming up though right like
sometimes some guys warming up they'll
just they're just trying to get their
body yeah they're not really trying to
look like a fighter right not trying to
look like sharp like they're gonna be
inside the inside the cage and yeah I
mean so shock want to see if you can
find that Chuck Liddell hidden pads it's
different it's different because it's
like it his balance looks off his
coordination looks off it just doesn't
look it doesn't look good you know it
just there's a you know here it is right
here take a look at this watch this
yeah yeah looks like it has no pop yeah
yeah I mean it's crazy to watch right it
just looks like let's see how he throws
that kick and and leans back afterwards
it just looks ah there's a real issue
with someone who's had that many chaos
even K out that many times like your
brains been scrambled that many times
like what is how was the connection
between your muscles in your mind
English bones nor nor logic yeah it
makes you uncomfortable right yeah it
does
like I mean and that's Chuck yeah I mean
one of greatest of all time yeah I don't
know I I don't I know at 49 also you
know 50 that's that's there's a point ya
know I almost feel like I would do it
again for for certain oh I'm not trying
to be a world champion I'm not trying to
get to khabib or Dustin and those guys
you know um but like Joe lausanne Diego
Sanchez somebody that's like from the
same era yeah at least a part of the era
that I was in somebody like that you
know somebody who I have respect for it
like it's it's going to be fun and
something but like I'm not and I guess
that's what Tito and Chuck is but it
also Chuck you beat him twice yeah you
know what he's be him twice by knockout
but I think he just felt like he always
had Tito's number but this is the
problem is like Tito wins now yeah right
like the guy who he never wanted to win
now wins yeah the guy who wouldn't fight
him when he was the champ now and now is
the winner like when it all said and
done
Tito K Odom and he Kayode him more
soundly than Chuck ever ko Tito because
when Chuck ko Tito he basically beat him
down and then Tito covered up but he was
conscious right like right Chuck put
Chuck out he put him out and you know I
mean it was a good shot for sure but it
just seems like you're dealing with a
guy who's whose brains are you know it's
just he's been scrambled too many times
yeah yeah prizes they made that fight I
am surprised at the Commission that the
fight happened yes if that's what you
mean yeah I'm not surprised that that
Oscar De La Hoya Tito Ortiz
came together and said let's get Chuck
to fight me right you know I'm not
surprised about that at all do you know
that they said there was only like
25,000 pay per view but that's what I
heard that kind of sucks that's crazy
horrible that's so low that must have
cost everybody money like I have my
Instagram followers what's a hard sell
and the undercard wasn't so good either
it wasn't like there was a lot of like
big names on the undercard that's gonna
draw people in where they're gonna go
well it's gonna be great fights no
matter what no yeah
though the undercard was not that great
no no you know you you saw the whole
show no yeah that's right you didn't
even know their wins but the UM the
undercard was not great um and then the
Tito Chuck fight I mean Tito looks like
the the much better strike a much more
accomplished striker in that fight and
like Tito Ortiz knocked out knocked out
Chuck Liddell is that that's like a
phrase I never thought I would hear and
it'd be real but isn't it also the case
of not just Kido remaining active and
staying competitive it's exactly what it
is it's that too but it's also Tito
skills got better yeah they definitely
got better jason Parrilla is an awesome
instructor I mean he's a fantastic
boxing coach and he really tightened up
Tito's hands and all his techniques over
over the course of the years they were
together in the last time Tito and Chuck
fought iPhone's hadn't been invented
yeah think of that yeah you know no
iPhones
people use in sidekicks remember those
you know were those things I remember
that flip up the keyboard it cheated and
everybody thought they were slick yeah
this was the last time they fought it's
a different and myspace was a thing it's
a different world man it's just it's
just sad to see it go down like that
where I mean it would be one thing if it
was a good fight if like Tito looked
like chalk chuckles like Tito because
Tito looked good yeah Chuck did not look
good right they both look good and they
put on their best fight and then T don't
wanna up winning good for him but it
wasn't that it was one guy was a just a
shell shell of himself so what kind of
fight fatigue oh or a rematch for Tito
would make sense to do that you think
would sell
there is there one Tito versus chill
will sell a little bit I mean he's been
calling chill out saying I want to kick
your ass but I think that was probably
for the pay-per-view numbers came in and
then they're like Oscar feels like now
he's probably got 15 voicemails on
Oscars phone Oscar and call him back
Oscar's just sitting there go [ __ ] Tito
Ortiz willing to postpone retirement to
kick Chael Sonnen ass again ya see but
the thing is he's gonna try to do that
with Oscar and Golden Boy and that's
gonna sell thirteen thousand
pay-per-view buys nobody's gonna buy
that well I mean if chaff jail gets hurt
on the marketing somebody will buy it
look if they could figure out a real
competitive fight for Tito against
someone who's got a big name I don't
know who that big name would be but he
could still sell some did you see the
did you see there was somebody posted
these I think cannot Dollarama posted
these two videos of Tito where it was
like somebody's asking him how does he
feel about this fight with Chuck and
he's like I'm much better fighter than I
was twelve years ago a much better
fighter I'm bigger I'm stronger I'm
younger she gets a little flustered yeah
said he wanted to outlive his kids to
look too that's the worst thing yeah
right you also say you also say he also
said the guys like so who's making the
money off of the pay-per-view is it just
you is it all the fighters on the card
or is it just you and Chuck and he's a
yeah it's me myself and Chuck we're
gonna make the money off of the
pay-per-view you know he just gets flat
he just hours through these things yeah
well you know it's not a stalkers
business that's fighters business yeah
it's weird you know you're asked asked
to be several things and when a guy like
Connor comes along or a guy like Colby
Covington